(cheering)
- Are you ready?
- Yeah!
- Yes!
(cheering)
(rock music)
♪ Well they threw us in a
cage and there's no key. ♪
♪ We gotta find a way
that we can get free. ♪
♪ There's just one thing
that might be found ♪
♪ Gotta rock this joint
till the bars fall down ♪
♪ 'Cause everybody here's gotta
shout till we all break out ♪
♪ Rockidy, rockidy, rock, Fraggeldy Fraggle Rock ♪
♪ Rock, rock, Fraggle Rock ♪
♪ We're gonna rock our way to freedom ♪
♪ Gonna roll right back and seat 'em ♪
♪ Gonna flip flop skipity
hop, Back to Fraggle Rock ♪
♪ (guitar solo) ♪
- I've got this.
♪ Don't need no key, don't need no bail ♪
♪ Gonna bust right out of this old jail ♪
♪ Gonna beat those bars
till they drop their locks ♪
♪ Spring ourselves loose
with the Fraggle Rock rock ♪
♪ 'Cause everybody here's gotta
shout till we all break out ♪
♪ Doobie doobie doobie do wha ♪
♪ Rock, rock, Fraggle Rock ♪
♪ We're gonna rock our way to freedom ♪
♪ Gonna roll right back and seat 'em ♪
♪ Gonna flip-flop, skippity-hop,
back to Fraggle Rock ♪
(guitar solo)
(Uncle Traveling Matt laughs)
(Fraggles cheering)
- Thank you.
Now get off the stage!
(mic popping)
- Yeaaa!
- [Uncle Traveling Matt] Fraggle Rock!
- [Dave Ghrol] Security!
- You're welcome.
(rock beat)